KUNAL SONI: All right.
Hi, everyone.
Good afternoon or
I should rather
say a very sunny good afternoon.
Welcome to Building for
Billions on Android.
I'm Kunal, and I look
after business development
for Google Play in Southeast
Asia, India, and Australia.
And I've got with
me my colleagues
Ankur Kotwal and Neto Marin from
the developer advocate team.
Together, we're going to
be talking to you today
about building high quality
apps that look effectively,
not just for
smartphone users today
but also for the
next billion users
as they get connected for the
first time in the coming years.
We are seeing amazing
momentum in emerging markets
all over the world.
They're expected to
account for more than 80%
of smartphone growth
globally until 2019.
As more and more users in these
markets get access to devices
and get connected
for the first time,
they will increasingly
rely on their smartphones
to shop, to transact,
to communicate,
to look for information, or to
simply entertain themselves.
And that means incredibly
exciting new opportunities
for everybody here.
In order to be relevant and
successful in these markets,
it's important for us to think
about the important challenges
that users face and design
the right app experience aimed
at solving these challenges.
Let's take a quick look at
some of these challenges
before we get into details.
Challenge number
1, while we're all
excited about the growth of
fast network technologies
like 3G, 4G, and LTE
the across the world,
the fact is that it's
expected by the end of 2020
we'll still have almost one
billion mobile internet users,
or almost 30% of total
mobile internet connections
to be operating on 2G.
That's a sizable and
large segment for you
to think about and solve for.
Secondly, we see a wide
variation in the quality
and speeds of mobile leader
networks all over the world.
For example, in markets like
India, Vietnam, and Argentina,
the average mobile data
speed is less than one tenth
of what you see in the UK.
To top it all, broadband
quality and adoption is low.
Again, going back to
some of these markets--
Brazil, India-- you see less
than one fifth or less than 20%
of total broadband
connections in these markets
operate at speeds
higher than 4 Mbps.
Clearly, these pose
challenges in terms
of the overall
experience that users
will have within the apps.
Finally, data is expensive
relative to income levels
in several markets, making users
highly sensitive to data cost.
For example, if you look at the
markets like Nigeria and Brazil
the average per
capita data cost is
greater than 10x or
more than 10 times
of what you see in the UK.
So clearly, being able to help
users manage their data cost
needs to be an
important priority if we
have to win in these markets.
In order to help you
tackle these challenges
and support your growth
in these markets,
we've identified a set of
tools and best practices
that we believe can help.
This is what we
call the "Building
for Billions Framework."
The goal here is to
talk to you a little bit
about some guidelines
in six important areas--
connectivity, device capability,
data cost, battery consumption,
content, and commerce.
The goal is to equip you with
actionable recommendations
that you can implement
to make your apps perform
more effectively and
efficiently in these markets.
So what we're going to do
over the next few minutes
we're actually going to deep
dive into all of these areas.
But before we do that,
let's take a look
at a developer who's
already embracing
some of these guidelines
and have integrated these
into the overall app
experience that they
are driving with their users.
I'm going to talking to you
about a developer called
"Culture Alley."
They operate an app
called "Hello English."
Now Hello English is a
language learning app
helping millions of
users as in India
and outside helping learn
English-- as simple as that.
All right, let's take
a look at a video
and see what they're doing.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-My name is Nishant Patni.
I'm the founder and
CEO of Hello English.
It's an app that helps
millions of Indians
learn English in a
fun and engaging way
using gamification.
India is a wonderfully
diverse country
with 22 languages recognized
by the government.
But English is the
preferred business language
all large businesses
prefer to use English.
-Hello English supports over 15
Indian languages, 12 of which
have native font
support on Android.
Our users face certain
typical issues quite early
on-- poor internet connectivity,
devices with low storage
capacity, low processing power.
We decided to focus
our efforts entirely
on optimizing our
app for these issues.
We discovered that Google has a
bunch of tools that can really
help developers to optimize
their apps for emerging
markets like India.
We reduce the app
size from 16 Mb
to 9 Mb, which
immediately reduced
our uninstall rate by 15%.
Also the majority of
the features of the app
can actually work
without any internet.
-Today, we have more
than 13 million people
who are learning English on
Hello English from not just
India but around the world.
-More than anything else, we
are encouraged by the stories
that we hear from our learners
and how our efforts are
transforming their lives.
[END PLAYBACK]
KUNAL SONI: Inspiring story.
What we're going to now do is
get into six of these areas
and talk about specific
things that you
can start implementing to
drive and boost performance
of your apps in these markets.
And by the way, what
we're covering here
is by no means limited
to emerging markets.
These are good principles
to apply equally everywhere
globally.
Let's start with connectivity.
In order to optimize performance
for poor or intermittent
connectivity, it's
very important
that your app prioritizes
bandwidth requests
in order to ensure
that users have access
to the most useful and
relevant information
as soon as possible
without having
to wait on slow
networks, ensuring
that text is prioritized before
rich media and images helps
you accomplish that.
Let's take a look at an example.
In this demo, you will see
that the text loads way
before the images so that
the user can actually
start engaging with
the app despite being
on a slow network.
The second thing that
I'm going to talk about
is something which is often
overlooked by developers.
You should not duplicate
your data requests.
Once you fetch
something you should
be able to store it and then
resurface locally whenever
it's requested the next time.
Network connections and
overall quality is not static.
They change with changes in
location, network traffic,
as well as the local
population density.
And your apps should be
able to pick that up.
And by the way,
like I said, this
is a problem not just
confined to emerging markets.
This could to happen very
easily in the underground subway
in New York or a
crowded football stadium
the UK as well.
Using tools like the
connectivity manager
and telephony manager,
your apps can actually
detect change in bandwidth,
change in networks
and then adjust
bandwidth accordingly.
So we highly recommend that
you take these into account
as you think about
optimizing for poor networks.
Let's talk about images.
I'm sure all of us have images
or lots of images in our apps.
Images need special
attention as you
think about optimizing
for connectivity.
As a best practice,
serve WebP images.
WebP is a format which
has been fully supported
by Android since 4.2.
And regardless of what
the name suggests,
WebP is not just
restricted to the web.
WebP helps you
improve load times,
save network bandwidth, and
very in many cases often
results in smaller picture sizes
compared to formats like jpeg
and png while maintaining
the image quality.
So it's highly
recommended practice.
Your user experience
can degrade very quickly
if they're waiting
for a long times
to actually download images.
I'm sure everybody
would agree with that.
One way to counter
that problem is
to ensure that you use
the appropriate sizes
of your images.
So consider prioritizing
image requests
based on network
type or quality.
This helps you not only
save network bandwidth
but also helps optimize for
the memory that each image will
require on the device.
Offline-- I think creating a
great offline experience is
a wonderful way of ensuring
that your users will
be able to engage
with your app content
irrespective of what
the connectivity is like
or whether it
doesn't exist at all,
ensuring that users have a great
offline experience by making
sure that you're able to
cache data, store it locally,
and also queuing outbound
requests for whenever
the connectivity is restored.
Your app should not be
required to actually fetch
any image more than once.
So image loading libraries
like Glide and Picasso
actually help you
fetch the image,
cache it, and then plug
into the place holder views
that your app has without
needing to download them
again and again.
This can overall help you
boosting the overall user
experience and
overall performance
that users have within the app.
In this case, you will see
that while the app is offline
or the user is
offline, they do still
have a very
meaningful experience
within the app with
the information
and the data that's
already been cached.
One simple way of checking
how your app performs
in the offline state
is by simply switching
on the airplane mode on your
phone and checking it out.
That gives you a very, very good
example, a very good insight
into what kind of performance,
what kind of functionality
is working well when the
app is actually offline.
So go ahead and try it out.
And if it's not, then do think
about some of the other things
that we've spoken about
to improve performance
in poor networks
or offline states.
With that, we come to the end
of the first section on the six
C-framework as we
like to call it.
I'd like to now
invite Ankur to talk
about the rest of the Building
for Billions Framework.
Thanks.
Ankur?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Thank you, Kunal.
[APPLAUSE]
Hi, everyone.
So Kunal has giving
us some great context
around connectivity,
and I'm going
to start talking about
device capability.
As the next billion users
come online-- and actually,
this is true even of
the current 1.4 billion
Android users-- there is
a diversity in the type
of devices that users have.
Some uses like
small light devices.
Others like big screens
with high definition full HD
or even 4K resolutions.
Some uses like expandable
storage whilst others prefer
a really big rich camera.
And while this is
great for users,
it poses some interesting
challenges for developers.
So let's look at some things
that we can do-- best practices
developers can use-- to
support all of these device
capabilities.
And let's start off
with screen sizes.
The majority of
devices that will
be bought by next billion
users are actually
going to be low-cost devices.
And of course with
low cost devices,
you tend to find that their
hardware specifications tend
to be a little bit lower.
You want to start to
look at your layouts
and stop optimizing
for small screens.
Small screens will be
popular, but actually
moderate-sized screens
with lower density
will also be hugely popular.
And those are really
important distinctions.
With small screens, you
want to reduce the amount UI
that you have for
navigation, for actions
because you want to let
the content shine, right?
When it comes to density
however-- low density screens,
medium density
screens-- you want
to make sure that the same
content that you're displaying
is easy to consume, that
the text is easy to read,
that the images look sharp.
And particularly where
you're using graphical assets
in your icons or
action icons, you
want to make sure
you're not using
thin edges on those icons.
Because on the lower density
screen those thin edges--
they'll disappear.
And of course, you
can test this out.
Android Studio has
been running hard
with productivity improvements.
And one of the things
that they've focused on
is improving the
emulator performance.
So what you should be doing
from a screen size point of view
is setting up multiple
emulator configurations
and then deploying your app
to these smallest screen
sizes or lower
densities and testing
how it looks on those screens.
And you can make rapid
changes in the Layout Editor
now because Android
Studio has Instant Run.
So when you make a change
and deploy it on the emulator
again it's not repackaging your
whole app and distributing it.
It's just sending the changes
across to your running app,
so the turnaround
time is much faster.
So we can actually make
these changes rapidly.
Of course, next is memory
usage because low cost devices
will have less RAM.
And I just want to clarify
when we talk about memory here
we mean RAM, not storage.
We'll get to
storage in a minute.
You want to adjust your behavior
by the amount of RAM that's
on the device.
And there's one API that will
raise lots of warning signs,
and you should be
using it today.
And that API is isLowRamDevice.
If that API returns
true to you at runtime,
you know that in
your app you need
to be aggressive about
keeping your footprint down
because this is a very
constrained environment
that your app will
be running in.
The other API you can
use is getMemoryClass.
And that helps you understand
how much memory budget
you have in your app.
Now strategies that you can
use to lower the memory usage
are things like holding
on to things in memory
for a little amount
of time, being
more aggressive about releasing
it not keeping it in memory.
Images also consume
a lot of memory.
So when you have
a low Ram device
or when you have
a device that you
know you've got low memory
budget on just use a lower
resolution, even if it's
slightly lower resolution
than what the device
will be rendering at.
Because then you'll
still be able to let
that user use your app and
have a decent experience.
And we all love to build apps
that do background processing,
right?
Many of us build apps
that have services.
That's OK.
But what's really bad is
when you have a service that
hangs around, that stops up
and sits there consuming memory
but refuses to go
away, all right?
Because if every app on the
system does things like that,
that means there's less free
memory available for foreground
apps, for the apps that
your users are actually
interacting with.
So as developers, we should
start up, do our work,
and then shut down and
wait to be woken up again.
And we can schedule
those wake-ups
with an API called
gcmNetworkManager.
I'm going to talk about that
API in a few more slides.
But it's really important thing
to stop long running processes.
Let's switch gears now--
in a minute, actually.
I want to show you a
screenshot here for comparison,
and this is actually the
Android Studio Memory Monitor.
We've added a number of tools
in Android Studio that help you
benchmark how your app runs.
And so you'll see
these two graphs.
On the left-hand side we have
a device with 512 megs of Ram,
on the right-hand
side, one gig of RAM.
And you look at the graphs
and the shapes kind of look
the same.
It's because it's the same
app running across those two
configurations.
But what's important is
those figures in red.
You'll see on the
512 meg Ram device
we're using about 12 and
1/2 megabytes of RAM.
And on the 1 gig RAM,
we're using 36 megabytes.
It's the same app.
It's actually adjusting at
runtime to its memory usage.
That's why the shape of
the graph looks the same.
Those requests are
the same, but we're
being smart about how
much memory we're using.
And that's what you
should be testing.
Again, use Studio's
Memory Monitor
and the emulators or
even physical devices
to see how your app performs.
Now let's switch
to smart storage.
Kunal gave us some
fantastic advice.
You do not duplicate
network requests.
You should hold onto them.
You should cache them.
But that doesn't mean
you cache things forever.
The size of your app in storage
should not grow infinitely.
And that's why I
recommend you bound
you'll caches by using things
like the disk LRU cache,
or Least Recently Used.
And what that will do
is actually only hold
onto the things that
are being used regularly
and old things-- it will
expire them and remove them
from the cache.
Now if you think about
the user's experience
when they run out of storage--
low cost devices, by the way,
don't have a lot of free
storage to start with.
But when a user runs out
of space what happens
is that they get a
notification on their device.
The Android system says
you're out of disk space.
You should go and
uninstall some apps.
When you tap that notification
it takes you to a list of app,
right?
And their sorted by how
much space they take up.
Now think about it.
The user as going
to uninstall those
apps that are towards
the top of the list.
Because uninstalling one or
two apps they can move on.
They get rid of
the notification.
They get updates.
They can interact
with other apps.
You don't want your
app to be on that list.
So here's a tip for you.
When you're caching your
data use this API getCacheDir
and store your cache
in that directory.
What that will do is that when
the system detects that it's
running out of storage
it will clear out
the system cache-- that cache--
before it lets the user know,
right?
So you get a chance to not
end up on that naughty list.
And actually, often
what will happen
is when the system
does this you'll
find that the system
actually frees up
enough space on the
device that it doesn't
need to warn the user anyway.
So 1, you're being a good
citizen on their device.
2, you're keeping your app
out of the naughty list
of system apps.
Now many users--
you'll find that they
use expandable storage
because the main device
comes with only a little
amount of storage.
And so what you want to
do is enable your app
to be installed to the SD card.
And that's just the one line
change in your manifest.
You don't want to make
certain assumptions, though.
But it's really important
that you allow this
so that the users
can have more apps.
And last of all, if you
look at the screen shot,
that's just the
system settings app.
And we're just looking
at our app in particular.
This is an app that
I wrote, and you
can see exactly how much
storage you're using.
So you should periodically
do that for your apps that
are in development-- see how
much caches are growing to
on various devices.
This image actually
took me awhile to find.
It's really, really important
that we are backwards
compatible for our users.
Especially in low
cost markets, what
you'll find traditional
user behaviors
are is that either they are so
price sensitive to the devices
that they buy that they'll
buy a secondhand device, which
is older.
Or when they go to buy a new
device-- their existing device?
They will pass it on to a
family member or a friend.
And so what we see is a longer
tail on device life cycles.
So it's really important
that you make your app
available to all those users.
You should target you'll minimum
SDK to be API 14, Ice Cream
Sandwich.
Because you'll reach
most of your users there.
But you should also set your
target SDK version to 23.
23 is currently the latest
API, which is Marshmallow.
And in a few months,
it will be Android M--
whatever the name tends to be.
And it could be
API 24 or higher.
But you always want to
target the latest API
because that makes
sure that your app
benefits from the platform
features that come
on Android with newer releases.
Minimum SDK of 14 will make
sure that Android Studio will
warn you if you're using those
features without checking
for those API versions.
So having this combination gives
you this fantastic position
where you can have the latest
and greatest features on newer
devices but be able to support
your older users nicely.
And of course, we make this
easier with the Android Support
Libraries.
Everyone should be using Android
Support Libraries because they
provide backward compatible
components for you integrate
into your apps.
And in fact, one of them,
which I'll talk about later,
is the Design Support Library
that makes your app still
stay modern.
Google Play Services
is a library
that we distribute automatically
to all devices with Google
Play.
And it brings the best
of Google's APIs there.
And the nice thing is you can
use Google Play Services APIs
and know that your
users will have them.
So please do use
Google Play Services
where you can because your
users will continue to get
the benefits of those updates.
All right, device
capability was a big one
but a very important one.
Kunal mentioned that data
can cost up to about 10%
of an individual income.
So it's really important
that we respect that when
we use our users data.
And the first one that we need
to think about-- the first cost
that our user incurs-- is just
installing your app, all right?
We need to keep our
APK sizes small.
And there was a great talk
called "Putting Your APK
on a Diet" at I/O this year.
So if you didn't catch
it already yesterday,
you can catch it on YouTube now.
But what I want
to share with you
is that images are really
the biggest offenders.
Kunal mentioned it
earlier for data
that we were transferring
over the network, all right?
Use smaller file sizes.
When it comes to APK you
definitely should use WebP,
but you should also consider
using SVG, Scalable Vector
Graphics.
Because Scalable Vector
Graphic images, or SVG images,
tend to be these
tiny text files.
But the cool thing about them
is because they're vectors,
they render to any resolution.
And so they're perfect
for your graphical assets
like your icons in your
navigation bars and so on.
And it also means
a single SVG is all
you need to put in you're APK.
You don't need to render
an LDPI version, an HDPI
version, an XHDP version.
It's a tiny file to
start with, and it
supports all the densities.
You also want to
keep your code small,
and ProGuard is
the way to do that.
Because ProGuard strips
out any code from your APK
that you're not using.
Often our code bloats over time
and ProGuard is there to help.
So minifyEnable=true and
shrinkResources=true will also
strip out any resources
or code you're not using.
Now many of us use
third party libraries.
I just suggested some
libraries earlier.
I suggested the Android
Support Library.
That's built for Android.
When you're selecting any
libraries for your own apps
be very careful that those
libraries are designed
to be run on a mobile
platform, that they're not
these gigantic libraries
that pull in lots of code
and bloat your APK.
Typically, libraries
that work best on Android
are the ones that are purposed
built. And if after all this
you're still finding that
you're APK is too big--
and by big, by the way, you're
target should be 10 megabytes.
That's what we find to
be the sweet spot in many
of these next
billion user markets.
If you're finding you
still are very far off it,
multi-APK is a great option.
Because when you enable it
and you do a build, rather
than ending up with a single
monolithic APK, you can split
you're APK by density sizes.
So when a user with an LDPI
device installed your app
they only get LDPI assets
because that's all they need.
They're not burdened by
these high resolution files.
And the reverse is also true.
People on high resolution
devices or high density devices
don't get these low density
assets that are unused.
There's a little
overhead for you
when you go to upload
to the Play Store.
You have to upload
a few more APKs,
but it's totally worth it.
Data use is really,
really important
when we're talking
about data in transit.
And so what I'm going
to show you here
is that same app that we
looked at earlier-- Europe
the one that we built. And
here what I want you look at
is the three peaks that
we start with here.
These are the text requests.
And almost immediately, you
see them becoming really small
and practically down to zero.
And the reason for that is
because after requesting
those text that we were
displaying to the user,
we request images.
This is an example of
that prioritization
that Kunal talked about, where
we requested the text first,
provided meaningful useful
information to the user,
and then started
getting the heavy work.
Please run your apps through
the network Memory Monitor
and see what your
behavior is like,
see what your
experience is like.
And ask your users,
during the warm welcome,
as to what kind of usage
you want from your app.
Do they want you to prefetch
information ahead of time?
You don't have to make
that decision for them.
Because we have a
diverse range of uses,
it's always hard to find a
one-size that fits all of them.
It's OK to ask them in a
nice way that makes sense.
Everybody loves
their smartphones.
Everybody hates
their smartphones
when they die because
they've run out of battery.
And apps are usually
the contributor to that.
Now when we talk about
low-cost devices, of course,
it means that they're going
to come with smaller capacity
batteries.
So it's important
for us to focus
on optimizing our battery use.
The first thing we should do is
ensure that the device is not
being kept awake unnecessarily.
So go ahead and look for
wake locks in your code
and remove them, all of them if
you can, but certainly as many
of them as you are able to.
Because holding onto
a wake lock tells
the device that you can't
go into a low power state,
that you can't go into standby.
So even though the screen is
off, the CPU is fully spun up.
And that's bad.
That destroys battery life.
What we should be doing is
firing up our component,
waking up when we need
to, doing our work,
and shutting down-- not
holding on to wake locks,
not leaving these long running
processes like I said earlier.
And the way that we can
do that is with this API
gcmNetworkManager.
Yeah, I know it
says GCM in there,
but it's actually not
specifically about Google Cloud
Messaging.
The API is named what
it is but trust me
when I say what you use it
for is to schedule tasks.
And it uses the job scheduler
on Android versions that support
it or falls back gracefully
on versions that don't.
So you have a single API that
supports all your Android
users.
And the great
thing about this is
that it can wake up
your app with conditions
that you define.
So not just at this
particular time,
but you can say things like when
the device is charging, when
the device connected to Wi-Fi.
And if you think about those
two conditions, they're-- ahem,
excuse me-- they're very
relevant to these billions
of uses.
Because you want them to be able
to consume this data when it's
not costing them a lot of money,
not on their cellular networks.
You want to do it at a
time where you're not
chewing up extra battery, i.e.
when it's charging.
So use gcmNetworkManager for
all your scheduling needs.
If you're using
allow manager today,
that's something that you should
look at changing immediately.
Because gcmNeworkManager
is magic.
It's fantastic.
And of course,
when your app does
wake up don't have it do
something really tiny,
shut down, and then
wake up repeatedly.
It's better to batch
our network requests.
If we've got three things
that we need to do,
do them together
and then shut down.
Because then the device is able
to stay in that low power state
for longer.
Batching is important.
We've talked about lots and lots
of different technical details.
But of course, how we present
our information to our user
is the thing that you
must solve, right?
So let's look at content.
Touch ripples are
really, really,
really, really, important.
I can't stress this enough.
Because when we think
about our devices,
when we touch the screen,
we need immediate feedback
from our apps.
And touch ripples are one
way that we do that feedback.
We provide it.
And often I find apps where I
will have an index of content.
I will hit that content not only
will it not give me any touch
feedback, but it will be
unresponsive until it pulls out
the details page.
And that's bad.
If you're fetching any data
locally or over a network,
you'll app should
always stay interactive.
Provide some sort of
visual feedback to the user
that you're busy
doing something.
On the lower spec devices,
this is even more important
because it takes them
longer to do all of this.
On a lower connectivity,
it's really important
because it takes longer for
them to fetch that data.
Now Android devices render their
screen at 60 frames per second,
and you should
always target that.
We have tools in
the system setting
that allow you to
see how often you're
able to update your screen.
So have a look at the overdraw
settings in developer options
and see how your app
is performing there.
And finally, when we launch
our app for the first time
sometimes it can take
a while to set up.
Again, you want
to show your user
that something's happening.
So consider using what we
call a launch screen, which
is typically a big
activity that's
a single color and
the light image.
What that does is it says to
the user, "Yes, I'm loading.
I'm telling you it's coming."
And that's setting
the right expectation
that it might be taking
a while, but I'm here
and stay responsive.
Material design makes
it easier to build
for devices that are small,
as well as big-- screens that
are tiny 2 inch screens,
screen in our cars,
projected screens
that are 40 inches.
This is probably more like 100.
And so please adhere
to those guidelines.
It also means that when
a new user uses your app
they're already
familiar with how
to use your app,
how to navigate,
how to go back, right?
They're used to
that consistency.
And the Design Support Library,
which I mentioned earlier,
is part of the Android
Support Library.
We provide backward compatible
material design components
that look great on the modern
versions of the Android
operating system, as well as on
older versions of the operating
system.
You get that full
backward compatibility
that I talked about earlier.
So the Design Library
is really where
you want to go to get your
material design components.
There are also some
great community-- sorry.
There are some great
community libraries
that you should look at as well.
Material design is
something that's
interpretable by lots
and lots of developers.
So we provide some great
stuff in the Design Library,
but the developer community is
always moving ahead as well.
And there's no point in trying
to build an app for an audience
if you don't speak the
same language as them.
So consider their locale.
Consider which audiences
you are reaching.
You may need to change
what language you support,
how those layouts look and
feel on various languages.
Because sometimes their smaller.
Sometimes their bigger.
And you want to make sure that
the text is really easy to read
so choose an appropriate
font, particularly when we
talk about low density screens.
If that font looks
blurry at size 14 or 16,
you've lost your user
because they can't read it.
We support Noto.
We've provided this
open source font that
supports many languages, and
you'll see some Indic languages
here in the screenshot.
But try and identify
the right one.
But remember there is
a balance in shipping
your own font in your APK,
or using a system font.
Because if you ship your own
font, it adds to your APK size.
So just take that
into consideration.
So we've talked about a
lot of technical things.
But at the end of the day,
we're all part of a business.
We want to be
commercially successful.
And in order to do that, I'd
like to introduce Neto back
on the stage.
NETO MARIN: Cool, thank you.
Hey, thank you.
Well, as you can see, we
have many considerations
when we are talking
about how to develop apps
for these countries, right?
And when it comes to
monetization there are also
unique facets to consider.
So in these kinds of markets,
the next billion user
markets as Kunal and
Ankur already mentioned,
the users are
sensitive to price,
more so than the other
countries, right?
And therefore, it's important
for you to keep it in mind
when localizing prices
to these markets.
So for example,
let's take a look
at ways for monetizing in
such a diverse environment.
Pick classic methods you
can use to monetize your app
could be advertisement.
So please, use that
more for example.
We have in-app purchase
to sell virtual goods
or implement a premium model
if you want to do that.
Also you can use subscriptions
to offer a recurring billing
for app or your service.
And of course, we can charge
for our app as a paid app, OK?
But in order to give you more
flexibility to set prices,
we've announced new pricing
levels in 18 markets-- yes,
18 countries where you can price
your app or your in-app item
well below $1.00.
So for example in Brazil, you
can price as low as one real--
it's the currency in Brazil--
and in India, 10 rupees.
And as you can see here
in this screenshot,
we have many developers
that already embrace
this sub-dollar feature.
And it would be great if you
can think about how to localize
your price to these markets.
Here's another example.
It's a famous paid
game-- Kingdom Rush.
They saw tremendous success
after adopting the local price
feature.
They are reaching
200% more revenue,
even with a lower price.
And how is this
possible-- a lower price?
Yes, because now
they're more relevant.
They can reach many more users
with this local price, OK?
So today we covered
the challenge
that developers face
when building apps
for billions of Android users.
And to address these
challenge, we've
introduced to the Building
for Billions Framework.
Using this framework will result
in a great user experience
for the both 1.4 billion Android
users and the next billion
as they come online, OK?
And also check these
links for more details
of all the Building for
Billions Framework-- they
have both Android and web
framework information.
And also we've
published a playbook
that captures the best
practices for Building
for Billions on Android and web.
And you can get one
now on Google Play.
And also you can get one copy of
our book right on your way out,
OK?
Thank you for being here.
Bye.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]